Romans 1: 16-1
semicolon Galatians
3 6 to 11 key verse is going to be
11 semicolon Hebrews 10 38 to 39 okay
watch here guys right here watch this
passage Behold The Proud his soul is not
upright in him but the just shall live
by his faith notice faith is something
you do something you live out you will
live by your faith notice faith is not
something you simply believe in your
heart and mind and confess it's
something you live out something you do
do you see it you shall
live by your
faith faith is something you live out
you do you act upon are you seeing it
before your eyes this will be the
destruction of Reform perversion of Fay
this is the annihilation of the
Protestant butchering of what saving
faith is honestly I'm not exaggerating
the just shall live faith is something
lived out acted upon something you do it
is a lifestyle it's not something in
your heart and your mind and a verbal
confession faith in is living
out what God demands of you it's a
lifestyle now let's see what the word
for faith is okay watch here now
remember this key text because this is
going to be a key text by Paul okay now
here's the
link now open it up brother if you
can okay let's see what the word is for
Faith scroll
down okay it's amuna be amuna
but the word is
am now click on it so you can see what
the word means now by the way watch here
Psalm 9613 you see it says the people's
in his faithfulness referring to God's
faithfulness now go to strongs on
top okay what does the word imuna
mean firmness hold on hey what's the
definition guys
firmness steadfast f steadfastness
Fidelity I.E
faithfulness what does the word mean
imuna faithfulness Fidelity being firm
steadfast firmness steadfast fastness
Fidelity faith
faithful
Faithfully
faithfulness wow honestly responsibility
stability steady Trust than truth let's
look at the other lexical
sources
okay feminine firmness steadfastness
Fidelity firmness steadfastness you see
it faithfulness trust okay keep keep
scrolling and trust you get it man of
great
faithfulness see see the lexical entries
and the verses to back it up now go down
let's see there should be a couple more
lexical sources right breathe out
faithfulness show forth righteousness a
righteous man by his faithfulness liveth
abak 24 keep going scroll down brother
just showing you all the time it appears
and its range of meaning the range of
meaning it has set office stability
steady truly truth verily faithful
faithful to be stable firm
Fidelity amuna feminine of Amon
literally firm figuratively security
morally Fidelity see morally Fidelity
faithful Faithfully
faithfulness set off of stability steady
truth truth verily now let's see what
passage does Paul quote to Define what
he means by faith
pistus
pisto pistos although they have shades
of meaning sometimes the meaning overlap
go back to
Bible
Gateway anyway now guys if you're
listening here's the death now this is
what settled it for me and destroyed
Luther's lie Calvin's lie of what Fay
means Paul inspired by the spirit look
what verse he quotes to define and
explain what he means by faith scroll
down look at it Romans 1:16-17
here it is
guys for I'm not ashamed of the gospel
of Christ for it is the power of God to
Salvation for everyone who believes for
the Jew first and also for the Greek now
watch look what he quotes for in the
righteousness of God that righteousness
that God gives you is revealed from
Faith to Faith it's Faith to Faith Faith
from the start from beginning to 10 as
it is written the just shall live by
faith did you see what he just quoted
Paul a Jew a Pharisee who reads Hebrew
taught by Gamel knowing the Old
Testament cites the verse that defines
Faith as
faithfulness you if you're righteous you
shall live by your faithfulness by being
faithful here's the definition of faith
for Paul quoting habak 24 meaning it's
being faithful well you can't be
faithful if you're not obeying the
commands of Christ which shows that Paul
and James are in perfect agreement
ment now go to the next
example what does he quote Galatians 36
3 6-1 watch just as Abraham believed God
and was counted him for righteousness
therefore know that only those who are
of Faith are sons of
Abraham and the scripture foreseeing
that God would justify the Gentiles by
faith Now what is Faith let's see preach
the gospel with Abraham beforehand
saying in you all the nations shall be
blessed so then those who are of Faith
are blessed with beli Abraham so you
have to have the faith Abraham had
because he was believing did you catch
it believing it's not simply something
in your heart and in your mind it's
something that is ongoing it's a
lifestyle keep
going now watch though St Paul for as
many are as of the works of the law
under the curse if you want to try to be
faithful by keeping the law you got to
keep it all or you're going to be cursed
for it is written cursed is everyone who
does not continue in all things which
are written in the book of the law to do
them but that no one is justified by the
law in the sight of God is evident for
the just shall live by faith there you
go it's not keeping the law it's living
by your faithfulness to God being
faithful to God and being faithful to
God is to trust God to tell you what to
do and acting upon it and now God tells
us trust in Jesus and Obey him let's go
to Hebrews 11 Hebrews 10
38-39 Hebrews 10:
38-39 now the just shall live by faith
wow three Pauline Pauline letters
quoting habakuk 24 as definitional to
what faith is that Paul has in
mind but if anyone draws back my soul
has no pleasure in him but we are not of
those who draw back to predition but of
those who believe who are believing to
the saving of the Soul did you catch
what Paul just
said we live by faithfulness we live by
faith notice the faith you have is
something that you live out you act upon
you do so you are
believing oh wow so Martin Luther got it
wrong John celvin got it wrong and the
church fathers all got it right they
were right all along and these perverts
of the scriptures got it wrong they were
right all along the fathers but these
men got it are you catching it
now now do you want me to give you one
final example proving believe belie in
in Jesus having faith in Jesus is
obedience to Jesus is being faithful to
Jesus and to be faithful to Jesus and
believe in Jesus is to obey
him you want me to show you now here's
where you're gonna have to be careful
about the translations you read do me a
favor open up John 3:36 in The New
American Standard Bible 1995 Edition
John
3:36 from the words of the Lord Jesus
himself
here you
go he who believes well when I say the
Lord Jesus I keep forgetting this
particular section it's John the
Apostle who is writing these statements
by inspiration of the holy spirit so
it's not Jesus himself on Earth is Jesus
from Heaven speaking through John by the
holy spirit so let me just be careful he
who believes in the sun has eternal life
but he who does not obey the son will
not see life but the wrath of God abides
in him did you catch it believing in the
son is obedience to the son if you don't
obey the son you're not believing in the
sun did you catch
it and yet they give you a not footnote
saying the word obey can mean believe
are you catching it John by inspiration
of the spirit of Christ says believing
in the son is obedience to the son
believing in the son is obeying the son
if you don't obey the son if you're not
obedient to the son you're not believing
in the son now let's see what that word
is for obedience let's
see what's the word for obey scroll
down you see the word a Thor a a
negation Pon click on it athon epon epon
Aon what does it mean now go to your
strongs Greek 544
sir AO a what's the definition to
disobey Rebel disloyal refuse Conformity
did you catch
it it is obedience or lack thereof
scroll down so we can look at the
Lexicon if you stay there we're not
going to see it AO literally refuse to
be persuaded by the Lord
a let's look at the definition scroll
down a AES AES disbelieve disobedience
do not obey obey are you seeing
it okay
AO the imperfect
heon arist
he not to allow oneself to be persuaded
not to comply with scroll
down to refuse or withhold belief to be
disobedient keep
going to refuse belief and obedience
because if you don't believe you're not
going to obey but if you believe you're
going to obey to refuse belief and
obedience you caught
it now scroll down a little bit
slowly okay go on let's see apathetic
right strongs to disbelieve disobey from
AES AES to disbelieve willfully
perversely not believe disobedient obey
not unbelieving so Greek athes or epes
okay see it okay are you catching it so
are you seeing the spirit of Jesus
inspired John to equate believing with
obedience believing in Jesus is obeying
Jesus if you're not obeying Jesus you're
not believing in Jesus so the belief the
faith that God requires of you to obtain
immortality to be justified is Obed
obedience to
Christ is obedience to
Christ you caught it now final example
from our Lord John 1423 to 24 Jesus
answered and said to him if anyone loves
me he will keep my
word and my father will love him and we
will come to him and make our Bode with
him he who does not love me does not
keep my word there you you go from the
Lord there is no such thing as believing
in Jesus loving Jesus that's not
obedience to Jesus keeping the words of
Jesus that is the faith that the Bible
says results in the gift of immortality
and justification he who does not love
me does not keep my word and the word
which you hear is not mine but the
fathers who sent me to believe in Jesus
to trust in Jesus to have faith in Jesus
is to be obedient to Jesus is to obey
Jesus and keep his word and act upon it
that's also Matthew 72123 not everyone
says to me Lord Lord but those who do
the will glory to God the Holy Spirit
sanctifying us to the fullness of the
truth so is that clear
now what faith is being faithful to God
and being faithful to God is to live by
your faithfulness to act upon your
faithfulness to obey the Lord that is
what faith is